No
hi my name is grace I'll be through Jeff
no no you know your life is different
now
oh welcome back to my channel first of
all thank you so much for all the
incredibly kind words that you guys had
last week was that last week hmm I don't
know hey we'll get to this later that
looked like I was joking my nipples okay
it was overwhelming and made all of my
like metal parts rest with you know
happiness that said it's time for a
regular boring-ass favorites video okay
said last week I just want to make
videos that are fun and I love favorites
videos because I truly learn about
products things people that I would not
be able to find on my own and I have
stuff in my world that I genuinely enjoy
and goose hates me just screaming at her
about it so may as well scream at the
internet about it so let's just dive
right in first did you miss that I did I
was a girl from New Jersey I'm a woman
that was born and raised in New Jersey
and so I know my fair share of tanning
beds it is not good for your body skin
but I always opt for tanning beds versus
like self-tanner because I know my
artistic skill set and it is not
applying self-tanner or well years ago
self-tanner seem to be really streaky
really orangey but recently in the last
couple years I've talked about this in
previous favorite videos I found st.
Tropez phonetically pronounced tropas
and it is the for me best self tanner
that I've found you could apply it
during an earthquake in the dark and
somehow still wouldn't streak and it
would look natural but on top of that
they make a bunch of other different
types of products and this is the danger
pay one night only wash off face and
body lotion basically a body lotion that
goes on is self-tanner and it doesn't
get on your clothes do a little like
HGTV style test right now
here it is whoa look at that that looks
dark as heck and you put it on
and you blend it in oh and it blends so
smooth and easy well I mean the ring
light doesn't do it any real justice if
someone were to gently stroke you here
which would make them a total weirdo but
if they did they wouldn't have anything
on their head this is obviously from me
applying this but it just sets on there
and doesn't rub off on anything but when
you take a shower it cleanly comes off
so I've been obsessed with this it also
smells really good
no that's I have a candle lit this is no
it's not no it's the candle and it's
three point three eight fluid ounces so
you can travel with it I recently did
and then I got my bag checked at TSA and
i sat there like this being like try and
find something over 4 fluid ounces or
3.4 fluid ounces whatever I don't know
what then and he pulled it out and he
looked at this he goes this was close
anyway put it back in my bag
and I said this is fake thank you
I didn't say anything I was hungover
yeah that's in a second next can you say
yes say yeah you could probably see this
coming it's a plug for audible you can
take a girl away from YouTube but you
can't take the brand deals away from the
girl hopefully dear god the girl needs
brand deals to keep existing I've teamed
up with audible so many times in the
past and they're sponsoring today's
video autumn of you don't know is an
amazing save for audiobooks and you
beautiful wonderful strangers watching
my video your first audio book for free
when you start a 30-day trial with them
just go to audible.com slash grace or
text five hundred five hundred to browse
their unmatched library of audiobooks
10 the book that I want to tell you
about is broken toys tailors a sucky
love story yes this is the physical book
copy of this and yes I did talk about
this on my Instagram story but I sat
down to start reading it and I got so
sucked in sucking in that I didn't want
to leave my house but I had to go do
things so I downloaded your audiobook
version that she voices and I listened
to it first straight one day start to
finish or you can only say if you don't
know is a youtuber that's been around
she's like an OG before me and youtuber
I watched her videos when I was still
figure out how to make videos and this
story is the most intense fascinating
it's just a wild ride of a love story
that I've ever heard and it's all true I
can just kill the bug with one here I
was just fully immersed in it and all
day long everything I was doing was
trying to figure out how I could get
back to listening to this story and her
audiobook is available on audible
Britney I commend you for everything
that you've been through I don't even
I'm still processing it I don't have the
correct word it's just nuts it's bonkers
it was an incredible audio experience so
I highly recommend that to you but if
you're not into audiobooks audible also
has a ton of other things every month as
an honourable member you get one credit
good for an audiobook plus two audible
originals from a changing selection you
can't get anywhere else
numbers also get access to audio health
and fitness workouts that are exclusive
so go to audible.com a you DIBL EECOM
slash grace or text grace to 500 500 to
start
30-day guile and get your first
audiobook download for free did you guys
know I could spell sorry my scalp itches
I don't take care of myself well weird
that I'm telling you about all these
products oh okay we're back baby
can you see can't see ya see ya in a
random bag in my house I don't ever
remember purchasing it but I have it in
my possession now this is Urban Decay's
all-nighter waterproof setting powder
yes I think maybe it might have been
gifted in like some other urban decay
thing the rare few ones that ever get
sent to me because she's a beauty guru
sometimes I'm this and I was like oh let
me try this because I needed a setting
powder and it's amazing when it's super
thin this very cool setting powder and
it's waterproof
you know there's growers and showers
well I'm a sweater not a setter i need
help setting my face makeup because i
tend to sweat cuz I brought trying to
constantly push out the liquor toxins
that I put into it cute fun but this is
fantastic because it's super lightweight
it really does set my makeup play and
it's waterproof a lot of the other
setting powders that I used look like I
just got my face slammed into like a
mound of flour so and this doesn't yes
yes this is Kat Von D's Lockett
foundation I talked about this
definitely in videos in the past if
you're like me and you're like a full
coverage foundation this is the [ __ ] for
that I get very red under lights or
under heat so I'm always looking for
some sort of full coverage foundation
but when I bought this foundation in the
past they only had the full size version
is available and they were super
expensive and I don't like communicating
with employees at makeup stores in order
to be assisted in finding the correct
skin color match for me so I usually
just sort of guess and check and my
guesses have been extraordinarily wrong
so it's basically just gambling like
forty five dollars however I went on
Sephora the other day and I
that they had Lockette foundations in a
travel-size I mean that's a way better
gamble than the big size on this one is
l45 warm is the color is it the right
color for me not necessarily but it's
still a great foundation in terms of
coverage and what I like to do now is
kind of take a little bit of this and
mix it with like a covergirl or Revlon
or like you know CBS right ain't the
kind of foundation just to get the
longevity out of it and like try to mix
it to find the right color it's going to
Bob Ross it on my face it definitely
covers everything you guys would never
know how many tattooed dicks I have on
my face I got really inspired by poster
line I was on a break
I was he pray loving and I got a couple
dicks tattooed on my face yeah
oh the candle should have fun you out
before and that's how it picked up dude
did you feel like this is a nest candle
which I believe is what these commonly
referred to is a too expensive candle
I'm fairly certain I bought this in just
a bulk Amazon Prime now order because I
just started getting slap-happy and
scrolling through what was actually
available in Amazon Prime now and they
had this and I added it to my cart and
you know what it smells goddamn great
Birchwood hi and that's like my favorite
kind of smell I love smokier woodsy err
I guess more like musky masculine esque
sense I'm not a huge fan of the soapy
florals and this smells great I don't
know that you need to find this exact
candle because I'm pretty sure this was
expensive and I was a little drunk when
I bought it and rationalized that like
that was self-care so I think the bigger
favorite here is this birch wood pine
scent being a really great scent if you
can find it in a cheaper candle might be
very ideal for you it smells kind of
festive but also I yeah you calling me
out I know I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about with this it's just a
great scent I love it I love sandalwood
pine number two until up
I love wood I love hardwood can you say
yes you say can you see
you basically just virtually motorboated
me so you have to listen to this what
now this is my Mert you guys probably
already know this but I have a few
different items available on my
represents door the link is in the
description box below I have these
hoodies in a couple colors zip up dress
to repress hoodies and from social
anxiety pocket tees and I just really
like this part a lot it's a
long-standing store it's not like a
flash sale I will double-check and make
sure that it's still operating if you
guys are interested at all and I've
gotten so many compliments on this
sweatshirt when I wear it just from
randoms
I like making merch to this slightly
tied to myself but also mostly just cool
things that you could wear without
wearing my face or name on your body
that's the kind of merged stuff I want
to move more into you guys have any
suggestions for things or items that you
would like let me know because I want it
working 2019 to kind of build that out a
little bit more and see how she goes
next pose next
yeah say yeah yeah say yeah see Basquiat
bozhe what is this brand called
answer me camera I think it's Bosch
bozhe suppose you're super cool deep up
and I bomb basically this cooling jelly
put under your eyes I put it on top of
my eyelids and it deep puffs it and it
just feels so nice and this is something
that is super unisex you guys cry and
get puffy eyes to you guys get anxiety
and don't sleep and then get puffy eyes
too so this I think is something cool
for everyone and it's like the perfect
size to put in your bag it's so tingly
enough it's cooling enough and it
doesn't leave like a residue it hasn't
affected my eyes and any allergy sense
so I've been using this like the last
week and I love it so go check it out
get out of my mouth hair Paras foreheads
Foods is for mouths
I've devolved into a cave woman while
I've been offline did you know that I
think that's it actually I haven't been
making videos for a while so you would
think I would have more
favorites but I also just have not been
buying myself stuff I've been buying
time biding time biding time what's the
phrase I've just you know been living in
my like it's on my bed pretending the
rest of the world is frozen time so that
I don't have to get up and do anything
thank you guys so much for watching
leave a comment down below on what did
that I don't know whatever you want
until forget to subscribe to this
YouTube channel because I'm making more
inconsistent content than you've even
known me to make in the past what a
promise and the threat at the same time
other than that thank you guys so much
for watching and I don't know also if
you don't already please make sure that
you are listening and subscribed to
memory nice podcasters make it weird
it comes up every Wednesday there's
links in the description box below we
also have a patreon for it also we are
doing our very first live recording of
this make it weird at SF Sketchfest in
San Francisco in January if you are in
or around San Francisco at the time
please please please come to our show
again all the information is below we
haven't done a live show together in a
second so it should be really fun and we
haven't ever done a live podcast
recording together so come see the
inaugural lives episode of this might
get weird if you are available